[співають пташки]
[звук пили]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[стукає молотком]
Так що, на п'ятдесят взяв?
— Ну як на п'ятдесят?
— Ну так... на п'ятдесят метрів, крупно так.
– Та де п'ятдесят?
– Але так!
– Вісімнадцять.
Вісімнадцять? Не двадцять?
Треба було двадцять  зробити.
А шкода це дерево.
Та!.. На дрова!
— Та де?
— Так!
— Бачте...
— Геть! Як кажуть, пуд пріч [під саме коріння]!
— Не можна! [сварливо]
— Ай!
— Ось тут коріння, а ми його...
— Де? Ось так його врізати...
Ось так, ось так.
— Це файне яблуко.
— Та ну їх у баню з яблуками, вони ціни не мають.
Я дам, скільки тобі треба.
Це копійки!
— Не можна різати...
— Все можна!
Я такі дві яблуні урізав, ось такі яблука були!
— А чого?
— Хлів хотів на 16 метрів.
Там чотири кімнати я поклав. Яблуню звалити —
[показує] ось так треба було робити!
То ти просто мізками не крутиш!
Зрізати її треба було і все!
Більше серце в мене крутить, не мозок.
Ходи, маленький, ходи.
[буйвол мукає]
[розмовляє з буйволами]
А де корова?
Кажи, де корова, а?
[свистить]
До кожної тварини я маю свою інтонацію,
свій звук, свою мову.
Буйволи мене українською розуміють,
коні — німецькою.
Корова — по-нашому [по-закарпатськи]...
Собака теж... Ну так.
[буйволи мукають]
Ну що ви хочете?
Агов! Завтра йдемо гуляти!
Йди спати вже!
[буйволи мукають]
Ні...
Я забув яблуко, вибач.
[гірська тиша, завіває вітер]
Зараз я проживаю тут, в Сокирниці.
Я купив маленький будинок неподалік Хуста
і залишаюся тут, обживаюся...
[Мішель Якобі
Еколог, фермер]
Я живу в Сокирниці і готуюся до зими.
Я вирішила зробити паузу
у навчанні в університеті.
Я відчула себе повністю вільною
подорожувати будь-де.
Оскільки я хотіла побачити Карпатські гори,
то приїхала сюди сама.
[Ріке Фероніа де Фріз
Фермерка, підприємиця]
Я дещо прочитала в інтернеті
про місце, де живе Мішель,
тому мені було дуже цікаво приїхати сюди.
Не маючи, втім, жодного уявлення про те,
як надовго я тут залишуся.
♪ [лунає ДахаБраха з колонки] ♪
♪ [лунає ритмічна пісня ДахиБрахи
«Ой, за лісочком»] ♪
Зараз наша ферма — це двоє собак, двоє коней,
десяток буйволів і кілька курей.
[розмовляють між собою німецькою]
Ти їдеш з нами?
[кличе собаку, посвистує]
Коли я першого разу приїхав в Україну,
усіх буйволиць тут звали Юлька,
а всіх биків — Боря.
У нас було до сорока буйволів,
і не можна було всіх називати Юля і Боря.
Тож ми подумали,
що коли в нас є класні волонтери, ми їм кажемо:
«Добре, у тебе сьогодні буйволиця народила і є
маленький бичок, то ти можеш придумати ім'я».
На...
На... І все вже, яблук немає.
Коли буйволи лягають спати, закривай їх
в електропастух, але підключай до електрики.
А там зачинено? Там, де хащі.
В хащі не пускай, там мокро.
Трохи пускай до води, на озеро, і лиш тут кругом...
— Мішель, є в тебе доуган [тютюн]?
— Що-що?
— Доуган, що це?
— Доуган, щоб курити!
— А, ні...
Хлопці не дали сигарети?
— Одну!
— Одну?..
Зараз принесу.
О третій годині, коли підеш на збори...
Об одинадцятій годині
за київським часом я маю бути в школі.
То о чотирнадцятій за київським часом
ти закриваєш тварин.
Так, так.
На початку у нас було дуже багато тварин,
я не могла їх розрізняти, не пам'ятала імен.
Потім ми продали 10 буйволів і 10 коней
одеській програмі з реінтродукції тварин
у дику природу.
Після чого я краще увійшла в контакт з тваринами.
Зараз я всіх впізнаю і знаю їх імена.
[дзвенить дзвоник на буйволі]
Опа!
Тут майже безпечно.
Отже, наша громадська організація
тримає п'ять таких буйволів.
Кожен буйвіл має зовсім різну кров,
інший генофонд.
Він запліднює всіх буйволиць тут,
а потім ми їх переселяємо.
Наприклад, він їде в Буштино,
а з Буштино наш буйвіл повертається сюди.
Тепер він буде 3 роки запліднювати тут буйволиць.
А потім ми його поміняємося
буйволами із Горінчово.
З Горінчово дадуть нам буйвола,
а ми дамо свого туди.
Наші буйволи об'їдуть усе Закарпаття.
Потім ми з Одесою обміняємо буйволів.
В нас велика популяція.
Наша громадська організація забезпечує фуру
для перевезення і займається логістикою.
Двічі-тричі на тиждень трапляється те,
чого я не очікую.
Ваша жінка знаходиться тут.
Так, я знаю...
Ні, чуєте.
Вона шукає сірого коня, котрий втік.
Дуже цікаво жити тут, в Сокирниці,
особливо на краю села,
тому що це дуже близько до села Нижнє Селище.
В Нижньому Селищі вже є спільнота.
Я зрозумів те, що треба мати обидві складові:
тварин і природу, але також  спільноту.
Я зараз піду зверху пошукаю...
[розмовляє по телефону німецькою
про загубленого коня]
Коли тварини тікають із загорожі або від пастуха,
або вночі, я навчився відстежувати їх.
Я досліджую їхні стежки,
сліди і місця, де вони були.
Також, спілкування з людьми і коло знайомств, кожен має мій мобільний номер.
Це дуже важливо.
Мої знайомі теж мають тварин,
то ж я знаю, в кого які є тварини.
Мені можуть подзвонити, я можу запитати їх,
чи не бачили вони потрібну мені тварину.
Алло, Федя!
То Міша, німець.
Алло!
Кажи!
Не бачив мого сірого коня? Буяна.
Я не бачив, Михайле.
А там в тебе є ще коні? Де коні всі?
Кому дзвонити, хто там є пастухом біля коней?
[відповідає співрозмовник телефоном]
Іван, старий наш!
Твій брат Іван, так?
Добренько, дякую!
То що робити з конями?
Хто зараз з конями?
— Ігор.
— Де Ігор?
Алло, Ігор!
Так.
А ти в Стеблівці?
Чуєш, в мене є кінь, Буян...
Я його тепер тут знайшов, біля сараю.
Катався я вниз верхи, був біля колгоспу.
А тепер я тут з Каштаном,
він повністю мокрий.
Можна лишити на ніч Каштана і Буяна тут?
Прив'яжу жеребиць і залишу тут,
на обід точно вже заберу.
Добре, прив'яжи.
Дякую тобі.
[корова мукає]
[собака гавкає]
А той чорний у тебе звідки?
Буян? Вже давно...
Це друзі, великі друзі,
я не розумію, чому він втік.
А друзі з червоним?
Так... Каштан і сірий кінь, Буян.
Як ми познайомились?
Перший ти прийшов до нас.
На дубовий ліс, вже десять років тому.
Ну я і кажу, що давно.
Добре було, як в тебе дівчат
було тоді таких всяких...
Не дівчата, а туристи...
Так то туристи були?
А то ти казав, що то всі твої!
А ну, може бути...
А мені не хотів жодної лишити.
А знайдеш українську жінку,
котра захоче так жити як ми?
Я б хотів німкеню.
— Німкеню?
— Так, може німкеня була б краща і не втекла б...
[сміються]
Тут ти маєш справу з незалежними людьми.
З людьми, які мають усе.
Вони не служать тобі.
Вони допомагають, якщо тобі потрібна допомога,
або якщо вони цього хочуть.
Ти не можеш сказати: «Я плачу тобі гроші,
і ти зробиш для мене те, що я скажу».
Вони більш вільні в своїх рішеннях.
Вони не роблять за гроші.
Треба бути частиною спільноти,
щоб бути здатним звернутися до їх послуг.
Ти не можеш сказати:
«Зроби це, бо я багатий».
Я щасливий щораз більше
відчувати себе у спільноті з людьми,
бо це не так легко – просто переїхати в сільську місцевість.
Я це усвідомив після мого досвіду в горах.
Ти не можеш робити все сам.
Тобі потрібна спільнота, щоб працювати разом.
Отже, ти їм даєш щось і щось повернеться до тебе.
І потім, коли ти бачиш щось позитивне,
ти можеш це розширити, збільшити.
Якщо в тебе є маленький сад,
ти можеш посадити декілька дерев,
а через 2-3 роки в тебе будуть власні яблука.
Йдеш з нами?
Дуже багато роботи, знаєш,
ми робимо тепер накриття.
Так, велика конструкція, мало робітників і таке...
Ну, все рівно, мама зараз в гостях...
[з телефона]
Твоя мама?
Так, моя мама і мама Ріке тут в гостях у нас.
[з телефона]
А, супер, вау!
Дуже класно.
— [з телефона] А як погода там?
— Погода, як зветься ммм... бабине літо!
[розмовляють між собою німецькою]
Я народився в привілейованій родині в Німеччині.
Маю на увазі, що вони були
в різних частинах суспільства.
Мої бабусі і дідусі були фермерами.
Мої батьки стали бізнесменами.
Я усвідомив, чого я хочу,
знаючи обидві сторони.
Мої батьки дали мені свободу вибору:
бути бізнесменом або вільним духом.
Або стати фермером.
Це велика перевага і я бажаю,
щоб кожен міг мати такий вибір.
Вирішити, чим він хоче займатися в житті.
Моя сім'я любить це тому, що для них головне —
щоб я був щасливий і здоровий.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Інтерв'юерка
Наталка Понеділок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Максим Зінчук]
[Режисер монтажу
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Dakha Brakha
Sasha Boole]
[Субтитрувальниця
Юлія Леонтьєва]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]